en este vídeo seguiremos hablando sobre
la ley de oferta en particular nos
aseguraremos de comprender la diferencia
entre el cambio en la oferta y uso la
letra griega delta para indicar el
cambio o variación en comparación con el
cambio en la cantidad ofrecida
recordemos que la oferta se refiere a
todos los puntos sobre esta curva la
curva que vemos aquí tiene la forma
típica descrita por la ley de oferta
cuando los precios son bajos los
oferentes proporcionan pocas cantidades
y cuando los precios son más altos los
oferentes proporcionan mayores
cantidades así que el cambio en la
oferta significa un cambio en toda esta
curva por ejemplo digamos que esta curva
es ese 1 y vamos a desplazarla a la
derecha estamos mostrando un cambio en
la oferta y a esta nueva curva la
llamamos ese 2 este desplazamiento es un
cambio en la oferta de igual manera
podemos tener un desplazamiento hacia la
izquierda esta es nuestra curva de
oferta s3 estas dos curvas nuevas
representan desplazamientos o cambios en
la oferta cuando hablamos de la cantidad
ofrecida hablamos de cambios a lo largo
de una de estas curvas por ejemplo
digamos que t
el precio p 1 aquí y asociado a este
precio tenemos una cantidad ofrecida que
llamamos cantidad 1 y ahora imaginemos
que tenemos un cambio en el precio sin
que las fuerzas de mercado cambien la
curva de oferta
digamos que llegamos al precio 2
moviéndonos a lo largo de la misma curva
y como estamos en esta misma curva
llegamos ahora a la cantidad 2 así que
el cambio en la oferta es un
desplazamiento de la curva hacia arriba
y a la izquierda o hacia abajo y a la
derecha frente al cambio en la cantidad
ofrecida que es moverse sobre la misma
curva y asociarlas con sus cantidades
ofrecidas teniendo esto en mente veamos
algunos ejemplos tangibles para ver si
resultan en un cambio de oferta o en un
cambio en la cantidad ofrecida digamos
que el gobierno decide que el precio de
la gasolina está muy alto y decide
establecer un precio máximo hablaremos
más sobre esto en futuros vídeos y este
precio máximo está por debajo del precio
actual digamos que el precio actual es
el precio 2 y el precio máximo es el
precio 3 así que el gobierno dice que
nadie puede cobrar la gasolina más cara
que el precio
qué es lo que va a pasar será un cambio
en la oferta o un cambio en la cantidad
ofrecida este es un clásico ejemplo de
movimiento dentro de la misma curva el
precio estaba aquí al principio y ahora
el precio se encuentra acá por lo que
tendremos una diferente cantidad
ofrecida le llamamos cantidad 3 así que
este es un cambio en la cantidad
ofrecida y en este caso la cantidad
ofrecida va a disminuir suponiendo que
el precio máximo es menor de lo que era
el precio antes del cambio veamos otro
escenario en este caso aumenta el costo
de refinación de la gasolina esto que
ocasiona un cambio en la oferta o un
cambio en la cantidad ofrecida pausa en
el vídeo y traten de pensar en esto esto
es algo que aumenta el costo de
producción de gasolina ya que se refina
del petróleo sin importar cuál es el
precio actual esto implica un
desplazamiento general de la oferta es
decir un cambio de toda la curva y si
queremos saber cómo se desplaza la curva
pensemos desde el punto de vista del
ofertante con una cantidad dada digamos
que estamos en esta cantidad aquí y para
esta cantidad
el precio será este de aquí esto aplica
para cada uno de los puntos de la curva
podría ser este punto de aquí o este
otro punto o este otro se aumenta el
precio de la gasolina para compensar el
hecho de que aumentó el costo de
refinación del petróleo así que el
desplazamiento de la curva es hacia
arriba y a la izquierda también podemos
verlo desde otro punto de vista que para
cierto precio los oferentes proveerán
una menor cantidad pues tienen que
compensar el aumento en el costo de
producción de la gasolina
por eso el desplazamiento hacia arriba o
a la izquierda ahora veremos un
escenario que muestre lo opuesto ahora
imaginemos que el impuesto a la
propiedad de estaciones de gasolina
disminuye así que en teoría si disminuye
el impuesto a la propiedad también
disminuye el costo de tener una estación
de gasolina y como esto aplica a todas
las estaciones de gasolina en el mercado
no a una sola persona para un precio
dado puede ofrecerse una mayor cantidad
o para cierta cantidad el precio puede
disminuir de cualquier forma la curva
que se parece
y ese uno se va a desplazar como la
curva s 2 hacia abajo y a la derecha así
que nuevamente es un cambio en la oferta
pues hay un desplazamiento sin importar
la cantidad o el precio de la oferta en
la que nos encontremos
nos vemos en otro vídeo